[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
can you hear me am i heard
my
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
all right go ahead and talk real quick
make sure that people can hear you
what's happening what's happening what's
happening everyone should be able to
hear you pretty well
uh everyone sounds well man everyone
sounds good how is everyone doing cow is
still doing something real quick
so uh you know we'll me and me and
everborn well
we'll talk it up until cal was able to
get here definitely share this to
twitter man
your boy needs the viewership man i feed
off of it
it it it that's kind of arrogant but i
don't care how i get that sounds we're
going with that
that is uh that that's the new thing i
appreciate everyone for coming through
well this is the the attic show where we
speak the
the past the president and the future
gang i'm here
with ever boeing saga what is going on
man i think this is the first time
you've ever been on the attic show
it's i've been trying to get on for a
while but this is the first time i
actually made it so thank you i
appreciate it
yeah you always like hit me up like see
the thing is i don't check my twitter
for the most part when i'm doing it it
then like i'll have mad people be like
yo hit me that like give me that link
because i guess i'll be doing spicy
stuff on here too much
so people want to come out yes that's
that's always how it happens like i
never
like plan to come on and then you'll
talk about something i'm like oh
i gotta say something and then but but
yeah but this this is why um i
appreciate that you
you hit me up before so i said i haven't
i don't even know what we're talking
about today
but it's probably gonna be spicy so i'm
here so we got
xbox making big decisions we got a
couple things going on there
uh you know obviously death loop got
delayed we're going to talk about that
we're going to talk about
the the delay impactful general
i kind of feel like it is okay to
expect delays but i do feel like some
things in that scene is a little bit too
often i want to talk about that
and then obviously we got the issue of
death not being on xbox and whether or
not you
personally feel like that affects xbox
going forward because i do feel like in
some form or shape
we're finally getting this bethesda
purchase and off the bat
their first couple new games is
exclusive to the competiting platform
but we're going to talk about that here
in a little bit but you know first off
what does everyone
play what have you been playing everborn
saga i've always felt like you
uh like myself a very uh variety gamer
and you know we like to play a lot of
different uh genres but i don't know
what genres you play so what have you
been playing
recently right now i'm playing a
plague's tale
innocence and i was playing i didn't
even realize that 60 fps update was
coming and i just turned it on one day
and got smacked by it so it's uh it's
it's
it it's pretty good uh the missus
doesn't like watching me play because of
all of the rats
but uh yeah i'm liking it so far and and
before that
i was doing um what's it called ratchet
and clank so i finished ratcheting plank
and then
and then moved on to a plague step oh
that that's what's up what have you been
playing cal
uh i was playing dragon quest 11 for a
bit and my boy
picked up uh sassafree valhalla so i
started playing that
um other than that man i haven't been
playing much lately
but valhalla i will say is is
what i realized about playing assassin's
creed games or just games in general
nowadays that i'm a little bit older
is that i can't i don't think i could
put 156 hours into games nowadays and
the crazy
part man you know definitely okay
warning
we're going we're going on an assassin's
creed ramp briefly it's not gonna be
long
but look i understand the appeal to the
new assassin's creeds you can look at my
gamer tag
i have all that out there and it's like
i'm a huge fan of assassin's creed
but starting with origins i felt like it
lost its way is that
bad no i feel like assassin's creed is
probably at a a standstill oh
stand still with the stupid switch stand
so we're going to compete
we're going to continue we're going to
move on and i do personally feel like
it lost its identity when they did it
because i feel like
you know sure assassin's creed's popping
out and i feel like it it appeals to a
bigger
audience but i feel like people like
such as myself that
was raised on the older assassin's
creeds it's not for us
anymore i agree yeah
i was just saying i think i feel like
that the game itself along with watch
dogs is
it just like it seems like they're doing
a lot but it all feels super generic
right like the the
i i like what i like maybe i played
valhalla for
two hours and i was like this is just
like the last assassin
assassin's creed and i don't know like
it's not
it's not do i don't i'm not a fan of
this new ubisoft formula
and i feel like they're doubling down on
that with with uh what they're saying
the next one is gonna be
so i i just feel like the the the series
itself has lost me
and and cal to your point i don't
understand how a grown-ass adult
that has a job and maybe a family or a
relationship or whatever
is going to put 150 hours into anything
unless that's the game
you just say that's what i'm playing
this year and you're right you're
marrying it at that point
my thoughts on this is like when i play
rpgs i can easily put 156 hours into
rpgs
because it's kind of like a linear type
thing it's straightforward but
assassin's creed the problem i have with
assassin's creed is
the game doesn't feel like assassin's
creed anymore like assassin's creed you
had set missions you go out
you're trying to infiltrate this area
assassinate this particular character
then you move on
now they want you to build a base
recruit people
you got to do raids you can't even go
into an area now
and just wipe everybody out without
having your army with you it just
doesn't feel like assassin's creed and
then there's all these little dots and
things all over the map that they want
you to do it's just so tedious
that it just doesn't feel not to say
there's a bad game it's a good game it's
just
very tedious and it doesn't feel like a
sassy screen anymore so i
i feel like i'm clocking into another
job when i'm playing
right like and i don't want to do that
oh i forgot to say there's another game
that i was playing today
everybody oh you're a little loud could
you turn that down just a little oh yeah
yeah yeah let me fix that that's
that's that's the the software thing
yeah just a little bit uh
while i do that though um rocket night
adventures the one that came out on
steam from 2010
i'm playing that at the moment as well
rock i played the original rocking that
on snes
yes sir back in the day that was so fire
the music was so epic
he he to me he was up there with sonic
and mario
but capcom konami i mean never never
really did nothing with him until 2010
and i never even heard about that until
like right now
yeah it's crazy and i've always felt
like uh you know when it comes to
these assassins creeds look if the if
they had to do what they had to do with
assassin's creed to keep the brand alive
so be it you know maybe who knows we
have a scenario where if they didn't do
what they did
assassin's creed wouldn't be around
right now so it's just like at least the
brands there but i do feel like it's not
the same game
it's just using the ip but you know that
is what it is i
i was still playing because i still
think they're good games it's just
they're not what they used to be and i
don't think they stand on the foundation
that you know that the games were made
off of
but you know what we're gonna do we're
gonna move past that because i feel like
i can argue
but we'll not argue i can discuss
assassin's creed for days because that's
how passionate
i remember i i've played them all i've
even played all the ones they currently
have
my favorite one's black flag but we're
going to move past that you know
let's talk about death loop okay now
there's a couple things that i want to
talk i want to talk
to kind of scenario on death luke uh
have you guys seen the state of play in
terms of death loop
what's your guys's thoughts on death
loop and and
you know in general and the biggest
thing i want to ask you too is do you
think that
death loop being the first big gang
coming out of the bethesda's camp
not being on the xbox not necessarily
i feel like there are different levels
to this but it's just like the first
level is
it being an xbox exclusive which
obviously didn't happen the second level
is it being a multi-plat which would
have been a little bit uh better than
this next scenario because that next
scenario is
it not even coming out for their
platform so i do feel like
obviously business is business but the
fact is
this is their next big game and it's not
on their platform whatsoever
but before we get on that let me go
ahead and read this uh super chat real
quick
we got a 10 super chat from day ron
colon if i butchered your name you guys
know how it is we're going to keep it
moving
i'm dropping by to support everyone here
ever born glad the eagles have landed
uh keep up the good work attic kale with
everborn uh dcon i
definitely appreciate it we got we got
hip-hop gamers in the building
says attic my dude what's up god bless
definitely appreciate all the support
you guys are up here
uh definitely that like button if you
guys don't mind but i want to uh
you know cal let's start with you what
is your opinion
on death loop in general and then the
second little caviar question there is
do you think
that game not being being one of the
biggest games that's coming out of the
bethesda
of the the bethesda uh studio since the
acquisition
do you think it is a little bit of a
problem that that is
not on the xbox platform in general uh
well first
i think that arcane is an amazing studio
i love dishonored one
and i love dishonored too i thought
those were really great games i didn't
play the dlc
um i when i saw death i immediately
thought of
dishonor that's what i immediately
thought of i just thought it was like a
modern day
dishonor you're running around you're
teleporting using these different
abilities and stuff like that
and i think the concept is cool it
reminds me of um
it reminds me of like dark souls where
you have people who can randomly join
your game and kill you as supposedly
that's what the
second character is somebody could
randomly join your game and assassinate
you while you're trying to assassinate
enemies on the field
in the game um so i i i thought the
concept was cool
arcane has that art style so i'm not
really like
going to get on them about that i know a
lot of people feel like the game doesn't
look like it's anything special because
of the art style but that's just the way
they do things
um but as far as being on xbox i don't
think it's a big deal i'll be honest
with you
you know they sony knows what they're
doing when it comes to third-party
support
and they go out they pay big bucks for
exclusives they won the money had it
from microsoft and that's what they did
and they were able to pull it off
because microsoft in turn money had it
the whole company
but you know at that point they they was
able to pull that that off so they got
that exclusive and they got
tokyo wire as an exclusive so you know
it works in their favor but in the end
i think it's gonna turn out better for
microsoft because
you're gonna wind up getting that game
on xbox at the perfect time in 2022
that's supposed to come out i think the
exclusivity deals up september
of 2022. and microsoft next year is
probably gonna have a plethora of games
coming out you got starfield
coming out uh i think when is it as they
say uh next spring or next winter
um star field is 11 20 22 yeah holiday
next winter yeah
11 11 right right so you're going to
want them having that game drop then
you're going to want to probably getting
this
uh not dishonored you're going to wind
up getting
def loop exactly in september or october
for xbox
with all the bells and whistles and the
upgrades or whatever it is that
microsoft does so i just feel like
if i was microsoft i release i release
it on xbox
in 2022 as a director's cut exactly
yeah we gonna talk about that director's
cut stuff we got to talk about that here
in a minute
but you know i definitely understand
what you're saying cal
in terms of you know i do feel like
like like an industry look it is a bad
look and not necessarily like it's
nothing microsoft can do about that
but i do feel like that is the you know
let's say this game comes out and it
does phenomenal
you know one thing i like that that's
gonna show like look like
the studios owned by microsoft and
they're gonna make that quality of
games here going out for microsoft but
at the other end it's like
uh you spent 7.5 billion dollars and the
first big banger that they come out with
is exclusively on the playstation no
i i don't i can't i can't put that on
microsoft
well that's that's what i said i i said
it's not microsoft's
fault but as a specter like it it looks
bad it's just not microsoft's fault i
don't know if it looks bad though
i mean i mean we could say with the star
field let's say
that they didn't get in there and they
didn't get that star filled first
and then mike because sony was looking
at star field trying to tighten that
down
like i think you know as good as a game
as death loop is
it's still arcane arcane's a great
studio
but i feel like something like star
feels on another level and let's say
yeah let's say that they were able to
snatch that before microsoft went
came in there with the bag and bought
them i think we'd have a different
conversation because it's like
yeah i think you know i don't think it's
a big deal because at the end of the day
uh you know a year later we're going to
get it at the best possible time we're
going to get of all the dlc that they've
done with it with all the updates
they've done with it and i do think
that's not going to mean too much
in the you know in the long term wise
but if you think short term
it is a little bit of a stinging wise
not necessarily bad
but it's just like man man once we could
have got that
you know i do think there is that going
on but you know everborn
uh you know clearly cal cow's
perspective is like you know this is
something that's
we're going to be able to they're going
to be able to use in the in the long
term it's going to come out at a good
time next year
how is your opinion in terms of where
this game is how you feel about this
game
and the fact that you know the first
year won't be on the xbox platform
now i did see people in the comment
section saying i have to
i can't leave out that it's a year time
to year exclusive uh i definitely i
i figure for the most part people in the
comments section know that but
what's your opinions everborn um i i'm
kind of with cattle on this i don't i
don't really think it matters and the
reason i don't think it matters is
because
at the end of the day at the it first of
all i don't think that sony is releasing
it at the right time
because they're releasing it basically
very close to holiday very close to
am i too low no you're fine now you're
fine you're fine yeah
so they're releasing it what are they
like next to call of duty battlefield
and
and back for blood right yeah and and
it's
an it's another first person shooter and
then we know halo is coming
so i think that you if they released it
today it would be a bad look because
as it stands today the ascent is not out
flight sim is not out uh the xbox really
has not released
uh their own first party or
at least exclusive uh game for people to
play not
not really not yet so if it came out
today it would be a problem but in
september i don't think anybody minds
i think i think in september they're
gonna say well xbox has
not said i mean maybe halo will come out
september maybe not i think it's
november
but the point is there will be other
games and
i think unfortunately with the timing of
death loot i don't know i
is i just feel like arcane in general
has just bad timing with their games
they make these great games
uh dishonored pray and then um
everybody remembers them really in high
regard but then you look back at them
and they didn't really sell
like that well so i i hope it doesn't
get lost in the shuffle
it looks interesting to me but i don't
think this is the game that people
will will draw that conclusion and look
worst case scenario
uh if it does well um in terms of
people's perception of it and and
reviews
and sales people are just going to say
wow look at the quality of xbox studios
right and they'll know what's coming and
what's funny is this this uh
this super chat uh we got five dollar
superchat from urban ninja three one
three
this thing is if it's really good and
people realize that they have to get
another machine to play a sequel
that is definitely a really good concept
on that because
like look i guess maybe it stings a
little but me i don't care i got a
playstation right here
so like i'm still going to play like it
doesn't matter i mean it's on pc too so
it's it's not like it's
it's a definite exclusive to the
playstation platform you can still buy
it
uh in multiple different areas to buy it
but you know it
uh cal i do think that you know that is
a good point it's like you know when you
play this game
and let's say it's it's it's great you
know
received well then a lot of these
playstation people be like
what say what i gotta buy an xbox or or
play it on pc to get to get death luke
2.
it's free advertising i mean i look at
it like this man like
i i just feel like 2022 is going to be
huge for microsoft there's so many games
coming out in 2022 that they already
showed from e3 which was like
impressive enough and then you're gonna
have games that's releasing
uh a year later that were timed
exclusives that's why i'm hitting xbox
but i also think that what you got to
keep in mind is that i think red fall is
the bigger game
people tend to forget that as well you
know what i'm saying between those two
def loop was probably
made by the other studio but red fall
just seems like the bigger game
and more up microsoft's alley and that
that game is co-op and we know how xbox
guys love co-op games so
i think it kind of just worked itself
out good for microsoft do you want one
of getting ready for next year
you're to want to probably get it maybe
a forza next year you're going to want
them happy start
and you're going to have death loop next
year maybe tokyo ghost
ghost wire tokyo as well who knows next
year looks great for xbox
and think about that too right because
they say red fall is the summer
right so if red fall is the summer and
then death loop is september
exactly and and then star field is
november that's just on the bethesda
side
not even counting any of the things that
xbox announced that will be coming next
year
and any other like any other second part
of the game yeah
exactly or anything from first party
like we just we have no idea what next
year is going to present we just know
what's happening with some of the but
that's the content so
it's impressive the way i really see it
is like
at at the beginning of the ps4
generation like they really didn't have
anything
not at first i think the first like big
game they put out was um
what's the name of this thing it uh not
day's gone it was the one before second
sons
right and that that when did second sun
come out 2014 2015
um i don't know i'll look it up real
quick they really had these smaller
games
um before they could ramp up and i feel
like that's where kind of xbox is now
but then once they got going you just
had that cadence of game
after game second son second son came
out 2014 march
21st okay so yeah like
a couple months after i guess yeah so
you know
what what what i like that you know cal
pointed out there is like sure
xbox people might not get this game
coming out the gate and it's not like
xbox doesn't want this game it's just
like a previous
uh of things it would cost way too much
money to to validate trying to break
this agreement and
right you know it would cost them
probably double what it cost sony
to get this because they would have
payback they have to pay any kind of
lawyer fees
it would be a very big headache and
that's if sony
doesn't fight them on it so you know at
the end of the day
it's still coming i do feel like game
pass takes the edge off a little bit so
when the xbox community does get it
it's gonna be in the subscription
service that a lot of them already have
and then not to mention what cal said
you're gonna get deadfall
and you're gonna get deadfall the
director's cut
and you're going to get um red fall all
within probably six months of each other
right right exactly so you know
in front in terms of this you know it's
like i said i've always felt like
being the kind of fan that i am i would
appreciate it this year but
got to be realistic about it uh it's a
business move the business was already
decided long before microsoft bought it
and there's not a whole lot anyone can
do about that
but you know uh if there's anything
anyone else you know uh what is the
impressions you know because we kind of
talked about like the xbox side of it
i want to know you guys impression on
death loop in general like
i feel like it definitely looks like a
game made straight of arcane
and i want your guys's opinion on what
you've seen because to me personally
i was always i can't get down on it
because it's not dishonored three
i don't know why it's like that mental
barrier every time i saw anything i was
like
oh that's cute but it's not dishonored
three i don't care but
i can honestly this last day to play it
really opened my eyes a little bit
and i think i'm willing to give it a
little bit more of a chance what are
your guys's opinion on it
well i'm definitely copying it when it
dropped see i'm not opposite like it
didn't
it didn't uh i was more hyped for it
before i saw
the uh that that state of play and i
kind of feel like
i can i like it's not a day one for me
right um i think that like i will buy it
on playstation
if i'm ready to play it at that time
like i'm interested in it
but i'm not hyped for it if that makes
any sense like
yeah i totally see it's one of those
things where you look at it
and you're like yeah you know this looks
interesting but is it enough to go
out of the ecosystem that i currently
have
well i mean i got a i got a ps5 too it's
just like i know i'll be playing other
things at that time
and i'm on this thing where i feel like
every time every one of these games
and no no uh platform holder or studio
is immune to it
you buy a game day one it's buggy as
hell
and now we're saying these games are 70
which is fine
right but what i'm saying is i've bought
too many games and then
they're in my collection i bought them
day one and i don't get to play them
i don't get time to play until six
months later right
and for me i'm just like at this point
i'm i'm thinking about not buying games
day one
let him figure out the kinks and i'll
probably get it at a discount when i do
when i do pick it up yeah so i
definitely understand where you're
coming from there because
like we do live in a time where we
should expect products to work day one
but they never do half the time
and i do feel like that is starting to
even come on my mindset it's like
yo why should i spend day one spend that
60 70 bones and then
nine times out of ten i can't play for
two weeks because they're trying to fix
the game post
launch return is definitely a private
example
i didn't have a lot of issues with
fraternal when i first started playing
it but then i got to the point
where i would be really good in a run
and it would just crash and
it would be very frustrating because the
game is based on not
restarting the game when you start one
let me tell you let me tell you what
happened to me in return
like i i'm i'm i i i got hit with the
door bug
right and that was after three hours of
playing
and then there's other times where uh
okay i'm at i'm at the first boss
i made it all the way to him again and
then i get there and i got like 10
percent health
so i say okay i'm gonna go back to the
ship and
and and do the sleep thing to recharge
my health i get back to the ship
and the sleep function doesn't work
right
and and then you'll have other times
where you can't even make it back to the
ship
unless you have the grappling hook but
if you don't have that yet it doesn't
work so
for me i put in like 10 hours into that
game
and whether it's a bug or just a bad run
all those hours are wasted i can't do
that right
it's like that like uh playing
playing assassin's creed forever like
for me
i got a certain amount of time i want to
play and i i can't do a game like that
especially if it's going to have those
kind of bugs yeah i totally understand
and you know the biggest thing i want to
bring up to
is just like i feel like us as consumers
we
we should expect a functioning product
and it's
i've always been on the kind of
standpoint that every now and then the
game being
busted at launch is acceptable you know
what i'm saying but it's kind of the
point where it feels like every game got
issues whether it's networking issues
where you can't play the game at day one
or it's just technical issues where you
fall in the map
outriders like we could literally name
probably three or four games this year
but that would take forever and i think
we will
get away from uh you know the the point
of the show you know
i want to talk about delays speaking of
all these technical issues all these
networking issues
a lot of delays have been happening in a
world
before the pandemic we had a lot of
delays so what i want to ask you guys
what i want to discuss is
first off is delays acceptable i think
that they are
uh but i do feel like sometimes we give
people a little bit too much leeway in
terms of how they
announce delays let's take example sony
with god of war
did anyone in this room have the
confidence that that game was coming out
in 2021
never once uh and i i
actually had a big problem with that
because it's like they
they purposefully told you that
they showed you a jpeg just before
launching to get everybody hyped they
they knew it was never coming out
and like i don't think they they ever in
their mind
thought that uh god of war ragnarok was
coming out in 2021
and you know yeah we're going to bring
that up because that's one of the things
i want to talk about
uh you know we're going to go to cal
here first but cal question i have for
you
is i understand delays are inevitable
and i think
nine times out of ten a delayed game
always results in a better product
but my question to you is do you think
that there are scenarios where
a game should not have been delayed and
not necessarily that it doesn't need
more time
that they sh that they they jumped the
gun for say like this god of war thing
where
they deliberately gave us a release date
knowing that they were going to delay it
and do you think those kind of scenarios
validate a response from gamers it's
like yo
why would you even tell me if this game
is coming out 2021
if you had zero zero shots of
actually giving us 22 on a release date
i do feel like those scenarios
are validated a response a negative
response from the community
and it's like look like if you didn't
think this game was going to be 20 21
why even say it do you do what's your
opinions on that kyle
i'll be honest with you i don't think
that's a bad thing
um i used to think it was a bad thing
because i used to be like
you know why now something so early when
it could be you know canceled or
something like that
um but when i look at what microsoft has
gone through
and like you're waiting for major news
on on big
aaa titles and big games like that and
you you're looking for anything to be
announced when you once you finally get
those announcements even if they're far
out which is what microsoft have done
with games like about
and perfect dark and all that stuff like
that we know those games are coming but
the excitement
for those games has us all excited and
waiting for it
to happen like you know when you start
getting into these little debates about
what microsoft has and what they're
delivering
you can sit up there well we got a vow
we got uh state of the k3 we got
you know perfect dark you got forza
motorsport and
um you know so on and so forth all these
games dropping over the next couple of
years
it's a great outlook it's good to see
what's happening
in the future even if those delays hit
because you
you're waiting on it like you know that
is there the anticipation
is there so i get playstation i
understand what they're trying to do
they're trying to make sure that their
fans
continue to support them and be excited
for what they have coming
by announcing we got god of war ragnarok
coming and stuff like that even if it is
delayed
it may not sit well with the fan base
but when you talk to these guys look
this is how they talk oh
we got horizon zero dawn two dropping
god awards coming out gran
gran turismo is not coming out no time
soon gran turismo is coming out so
all these guys are excited about these
things these companies know exactly
what they're doing and if they have to
delay games to make sure that they're
right
they're going to do it and it's probably
the smartest thing to do than to maybe
push something out
which isn't going to be successful um
like maybe a crackdown 3 which i was
completely disappointed with i didn't
play the game i wasn't playing and
played it anyway
um but i knew that when i played it at
e3
i said to myself okay this is
interesting but it's not
it's not what i thought it was going to
be the way they hyped it up when it came
with
the cloud and all that stuff like that
and then once it finally launched
and we got to actually see it and see
the multiplayer it was even more of a
disappointment because i feel like it
just
never lived up to any of the potential
that it was trying to be so
and they couldn't delay any longer it
had already been delayed so
much so i just want them to i just want
to make sure that um
you know when you delay a game that you
are making sure it lives up to its
potential and what you want the vision
of the game to be
which is why i'm glad it delayed halo
and i'm looking forward to this
this fall so let let me push back at you
a little bit because i see people
in the chat yeah i was gonna do it yeah
so
i don't think there's an issue with
generating height we see it with favor
we've seen over the last of us too we've
seen no go sushima
i personally think there's an issue of
giving a release date on a release date
that you have no intentions on keeping
for instance if they would have came out
and said all of that nice stuff and then
they said
at the end of that nothing is
coming soon to the theaters the year you
get what i'm saying i'm joking
i don't think a lot of people would have
had an issue but the fact that they came
out there and they they
i don't think anyone has an issue of
announcing a game
because i i think sony's always done a
fantastic job at it they've announced
the game years before it comes out
and they're just showing you yo this
game exists i think the issue with it
was we're going to show you that this
game exists but then we're going to
kind of false advertise this game's
coming out next year
so uh that that is the the feedback and
the pushback uh
what do you feel about that so was that
for me
yeah let let cal rebundle that and then
you now i just want to say that i
i get that i understand that but again
you're talking about
you're a business you have major
competition microsoft was making all
these moves
and you got to keep people interested in
your platform you got to keep people
looking for the next big aaa title and
that's what you're known for so going
ahead even if you're false advertising
it's got people aware that the next hot
game which is god of war which is
probably their biggest game at this
point
part two is coming out and you should be
excited about that you should buy your
playstation 5 to play
god of war ragnarok even if production
started in 2019
and it's gonna take five years for it to
come out guess what
it's in production and it's coming so i
just think that
as much as fans may gripe about that um
i get the marketing ploy i get the
strategy with some of these things when
you
you have something to present like you
see microsoft present their e3 and sony
didn't show up
then they showed us state of play a lot
of people was disappointed with the
state of play because they don't
right now don't have anything major
like on the level of god of war or
horizon zero dawn to show
when they do they'll obviously present
it but at this point they don't and
right now the momentum
is with microsoft at the microsoft has
such a good showing at e3 so i just feel
like
um as as as much as people want to gripe
about dates
the fact that we're aware of what's in
development
is uh is a w for those companies
all right so i know you had uh something
you wanted to save reborn
yeah yeah yeah so the thing is god of
war is not delayed
because it that [ __ ] was never coming
out in 2021 anyway to my right
right and then the other part of it i i
do think it's i
i think it's like there's a difference
between
blatantly like lying right
like you you you are you are the market
leader in terms of sale in
in terms of sales for the last
generation and so far this generation
and your your sort of mind share
all of that there's no reason to lie
about that so if
if horizon doesn't come out this year
the game is almost ready and they're
trying to get it there
right that that is a that's totally fine
right they're
aiming for 2021 with horizon right they
never ever were going to put out god of
war
this year and they knew that and to me
that that's really the problem that i
find right
you you you there's no reason for this
and they keep doing it over and over
again and i think the reason
i i think they do have a lot of things
to show i just think that they don't
have to
or they feel like they don't have to
right because
they know that that whenever they do
show us something people will say yes
more please
right so so it i
i really am against this idea that we
say
and i think i think cog was saying this
on on this week's show like
not because you've done you've put out
these games that means you can just
treat your
your customers i'm a playstation 5
customer right
you can't just say this and and say well
i don't need to show you anything and i
can tell you whatever i feel like at the
moment
and you gonna eat it up anyway to me
that's not cool like you didn't have to
do that you could have just showed
the ragnarok jpeg and say it's coming
don't work when it's ready
don't worry about when it's coming yeah
i understand playstation's
fan base this is this is what i'm saying
this is a
difference between xbox gamers and
playstation gamers you know what i'm
saying
they live off of that and that's a
that's a major difference especially the
hardcore fan base
so it's like sony knows exactly
what they're doing and who they're
placating to
so you saying that customers like to be
lied to
no they like to they like to be aware of
what's coming and
what's going to be a huge major title so
they can have more
ammo when they want to go at xbox guys
or they want to be able to be like we
got this coming or that's coming in
you see how playstation uh executives
talk
we're going to focus on these aaa games
only like this is our new focus
we're going to put all our money into
these type of titles whereas microsoft
was talking about diversity
microsoft was talking about we're not
trying to uh placate to
any one type of game you know you've had
phil come out and say that he needs more
games that are
play uh uh that are toward children
younger ages
and stuff like that in his library which
they have honestly
microsoft besides nintendo probably has
one of the best
library games that they own because of
rare
where they can actually come out with a
lot of platformers but they haven't done
that yet they haven't found the team
to pick up those games yet so i just
feel like
like sony knows what they're doing when
it comes to that i think microsoft
uh because they didn't have anything for
so long to talk about
like everybody wants to see fable right
but
they not showing us fable we know fables
in production
but we haven't seen fable yet but you
guys feel talking about just look at
horizon zero uh look at uh forza horizon
and you can see the work that's going to
go into fable that's exciting
content but we don't have a date for
fable we don't know when it's dropping
but we know it's in production
same thing with a vowel a vowel game
with a cgi trailer we have no idea what
a vowel looks like
but everybody's talking about how hyped
they are for a valve when it comes out
because we know how good obsidian is so
you know i just think that i i get it
nobody wants to be lied to
but when you are some something like a
product
yeah some of us exactly when you when
you're being when you are selling a
product
you got to have ammunition to give to
the people so they know
okay i'm going to go out and buy this
and this is the reason why and i think
that's what uh that's what sony has done
i don't know
i just find that scared people lie right
i don't even think it's scared people i
just think that they've gotten so
comfortable with
yeah what was saying whatever they want
to say and you know
i think sony well shout out to first off
shout out to dylan with the 1999
super chat keep up the good work fellas
let me tell let me say something a
little bit about dylan
like me and this dude argue a lot man we
don't really have a whole lot of
same taste in games i literally
downloaded nba
20 56 i don't know what day it was it
just because
you know he was playing it a lot and i
know you know he wanted
to for me at least to try it i
downloaded it i tried it it's actually a
fun game
come from someone that literally knows
no one on it i literally asked him
what's the best person for this position
there's not a lot of people like
diller in this community diller's a very
serious tone person if i want feedback
from my youtube channel i go to diller
gaming because i know at the end of the
day
i can say yo what's this thumbnail
everyone telling me it's hot dill will
be like
yo this is something wrong here this
font's whack what are you doing here
question mark and i got to respect you
for that dealer because there's a lot of
people that do that a lot of people like
to
to stay in the middle and they don't
like to give their 100 opinion
and if they do they kind of like
sugarcoat it back just a little bit they
don't want to be too too aggressive
and you do not give a [ __ ] about
aggressiveness you will say whatever you
want and i got to respect that but you
know
reel it back a little bit you know i
gotta respect because i feel like sony
in terms of what's going
on with sony i think sony has the
thought process
you know we're gonna i don't even think
the generations thing
was really their fault i think the
generations thing like like with
microsoft you know
it's one thing to say in one month and
then six months later
the company drastically restructures
stuff we want to do this differently we
want to do that differently
i honestly feel like there's a lot of
scenarios
that happens with you know with
microsoft that they love
misquoting phil like like crazy he'll
say something that has nothing to do
with what's going on
and then they'll quote it you know with
the we don't see sony as our competition
they'll tell you they'll they'll leak
that article over and over again
and they'll fail to say that he was
talking about cloud services when he was
talking about that
but they won't let you see that when
they were talking about the playstation
and
uh you know we uh single player games
don't have the effect they did
he wasn't talking about that they have
no effect he was talking
look what are the biggest games that's
going on right now
fortnite warzone apex legend obviously
these games weren't back there but i'm
using the same analogy as he was using
sure single player games have that
driven but it's not what's hot hot right
now and he wasn't wrong
and i think you know i do feel like i'm
not going to let
jim dance with ryan's 100 off because
they are
some things that he say that i'm like
why would you ever
come out that openly and say something
with the generations thing
i do think sony is crazy for putting on
their announcements that
gran turismosa playstation 5 exclusive
but then when it comes around to
nothing's a playstation 5 exclusive it
looks like and
they got to look at that they got to
find out you know maybe we need
to really address how we're announcing
stuff and we need to stop
having definite answers to all these
questions because it's blowing up in our
face
that shout out to optimus code gaming
from the inside out man that's a crazy
name optimus
uh 25 superchat added because a fraud
ever born is a bot
yeah i i'm definitely a fraud man you
know i'm a fraud for these games man i'm
a fraud for these games
shout out talk to his coach he's always
been a good dude and you know
what i want to talk you know cal you
didn't really go into too much and i
want to get your opinion on that
for saying when it comes to exactly what
is going
on with my sony and do you think that
the way they've marketed stuff could be
improved a little bit or do you think i
do think it's a little 50 50. i think
some of the things like the generations
talk
it was coming from a previous standpoint
that maybe that was the direction but it
changed
but as far as like the gran turismo
stuff i do think they're being a little
bit
close to the chest when it comes to
games being cross-platform that
don't necessarily cross-platform they i
don't think sony instead of the grand
trismus
came out 100 lying but i do think that
they
they hug that that that that that border
line between lying and being truthful
i think they're for the most part
they're trying to keep stuff
out and not necessarily confirming stuff
like we're going to confirm stuff at the
very last minute and
i want your opinion on that kyle i i'll
be honest with i
continue to think that they are trying
to keep with microsoft
i i truly i truly believe that i know a
lot of playstation fans
and sony fans feel like sony doesn't
have
to compete with microsoft and microsoft
is beneath them
xbox is beneath playstation but
when you look at what they're saying
when he said uh
we believe in we don't you know we
believe in generations that's a direct
shot at microsoft
that's basically what that is and they
continue to do these little things
that let you know they are listening to
what microsoft is doing they are
watching
what microsoft was doing when when when
uh
uh what's his name the uh i can't
remember his name the
japanese any director now he used to be
in charge of something they
demoted him um
yeah right when he comes on he's like
you know we have
the playstation collection it's no game
pass but we got
the playstation collection and people
can play that like
they're listening and watching what
microsoft is doing and doing everything
in their power to compete with microsoft
without competing
with microsoft putting their games on on
pc
a year later is competing with xbox
without competing
against xbox they are doing these little
things bit by bit
so being able to try to like stay
in a space where they're consistently
putting out
major content and letting you know they
got major content
coming out is is directly as a result to
microsoft with game pass coming out with
games uh
third party titles hitting it them
showing off how many studios they got in
the games that's being produced by set
studios
um what we can expect in the future
obviously forza horizon 5 looks
incredible
so you know they know gran turismo is
coming and they they're working on that
and they're going to try to pump that
out as soon as possible and i think
microsoft
has turned 10 working on forza
motorsport and that's being rebooted
so that's going to probably look
incredible but then do engine and
again i just feel like sony constantly
is trying to compete without it look
like
looking like they are in a space where
they have to compete because they've
been number one for so long and they
want to continue to placate to that
um so i just i just think that at the
end of the day
the little things that they're doing is
to say that
yeah we we have to market these things
to stay number one because again
video game uh or shall i say gamers are
very
finicky they will they will move on from
you in a second not the hardcore guys
but just the overall
like they go with talk you'll be
whatever's banging
you'll be surprised how quick you can
lose that hotness like
like look at fortnite fortnite was
killing everything and fortnite is still
a very big relevant name but i would
you know i would say that right now
minecraft is bigger than fortnite i see
way more people talking about minecraft
you don't see
fortnite's obviously it's still the king
of everything
but now it's just like as far as like
the media and the social media
uh you know people like dream has made
minecraft so much bigger
and i think that you know you go with go
for whatever the flow is and
you'd be surprised how quick that flow
just drops straight off
and it's like i've always told people
you know me cog has been very big on
this
people say playstation man playstation
got they got
they got the trends man they got the the
track record
and it's just like it doesn't matter
what track record you have it doesn't
matter if anything
people retire people leave people come
back people get fired
people are replaced and we've seen
throughout the years
that people will make the same mistakes
their predecessors made 20 years ago
don't think something's not important
and they'll change things up and before
you know it
playstation's in third place i'm not
saying it's happening this generation
but i'm saying that these companies they
got to keep up with what's going on and
i feel like that's why you see a lot of
scenarios where
you know it's even happened to phil
spencer uh pr will
you know they'll tell them to state
something in a certain way
and before you know it it's blowing back
on them because they're trying to keep
up with that trend they're trying to
keep up what's going on right now and it
ends up blowing up in their face
but you know five dollars shout out to
lucasfox for the five dollar super track
great
show guys keep up the good work and i
definitely you know
appreciate that but you know uh i just
want
in terms of playstation i wanted to be a
little bit more uh clear
in terms of how they do things you don't
even stop lying
yeah that's it i want them to stop being
very very deceiving that's what i'm
going to say they're going to be very
very deceiving
i mean look look what's going on with
these director cuts they're finding like
little unique ways to charge you more
for the money that you just
shouldn't actually get upgraded from i i
feel like you know i've stayed in my
opinion very vocally when it comes to
this ghost fushima thing
there's no reason you should be paid ten
dollars to have access to stuff that
you're
promoted when you bought the ps5 and i
see a lot of people you know
completely okay with that and i'm just
not it's like sony be very vocal on what
you want to do
and stop holding stuff to you look if
you would have told people
six months before miles came out that it
was a playstation 4 game
as well you would have got a lot less
backlash than you would two months
before the console came out
and that's all i want but but they did
that on
purpose right all of these things these
we believe in generations
and you don't um you know
we like to grow organically you can't
just throw money at studios and then you
go buy a bunch of studios
like all of that is just a different
variation of this is the way you trade
games
right and they what they do
is they sort of feed red meat to
to the optimus codes of the world right
like
so and it's basically like
they their marketing strategy is to
find a clear delineation between them
and their
competition and then drive that point
home
right so if you hear an article come out
that people are complaining about that
phil spencer says well
we're going to support the xbox for one
to two years the og xbox
for one to two years after launch and
because we don't want to leave anybody
behind so you you
you or your marketing team whoever it is
says
well let's that's a point people are
hitting them home
hitting them hard for that let's come in
let's look like the white knight
let's say we believe in generations
right
when you know the in we're just in a
period of consolidation now
because uh you know money is cheap right
now interest rates are very low
um it is a buyer's market um
a lot of people are probably gonna these
big corporations are gonna get
taxed probably very soon like the
corporate tax rates are probably gonna
go up
people are worried about inflation um
you're not making money because like i
said there's not a lot of interest
interest rates are very low right now so
you don't want to leave your money
sitting around
the best thing you could do uh with your
money right now is buy
studios not to mention you may want to
you don't want to get locked out from
any content that could come out so
everyone is going to be be buying
studios and that
is just the nature of where we are but
they
they want to make it seem like they're
growing organically why
because microsoft has said we are still
looking to
to buy studios so it's really about just
creating this
clear separation between them and their
competition and if they have to stretch
the truth
if they have to lie to do it that's fine
the marketing job is done
and by the time they have to fess up and
tell the truth
uh everybody will be on to the next
thing anyway it's a very cynical way
to uh it's a very cynical marketing
strategy um
i don't really like it but it seems to
be working for them
because the the the benefit that they
get
of serving people red meat um
far outweighs the backlash they get in
terms of time
right because people people will go at
them for like a week or two like oh you
lied jim lyon
gym dance moves but he already had six
months
of people saying wow look at what
playstations and nobody ever learns
right everybody's like look jim ryan
said this
this is the clear difference and then
they end up doing the same thing so
my my ultimate point is if you really
want to know what sony is going to do
look at what microsoft is doing uh two
years ago
and and and sony will ultimately do the
same thing so
i will have a game pass like service
sony will buy more studios
sony will support the ps4 everything
that
that you see now they develop games very
differently
right before anybody comes at me in the
chat they do
their their strategy for developing
games is different
but their business strategies they're
just letting microsoft run up the hill
take all the arrows
or you know those dudes you'll play in
halo and they'll see two people fighting
or destiny and then they'll come in and
get the cleanup kill
like that's what sony does so
i agree this is my point that i was
saying earlier it's like
they know what they're doing this isn't
like something that they're making a
mistake on they're deliberately
doing these things to pull in the fan
base because that's what the fan base
wants they they eat it up they love it
you know what i'm saying
and and then once you have everybody in
your neck and once you got all the fish
in the net
you pull it up out of the ocean and then
you got all this fish you know what i'm
saying is you can't go back and that's
basically what they've been doing
now it's not to say that microsoft
hasn't had their hiccups it's not to say
that microsoft hasn't had their issues
when it comes to messaging
there's been a lot of times that i've
called microsoft on their messaging
but microsoft has and it has been burped
enough to where
they're figuring things out and started
to get things
uh going in the right direction and i
really appreciate the direction that
they're heading
with their studios and what they're
developing and game pass and all that
stuff like that
so you know i think microsoft also
has the ability to take the risk
financially because they're backed by
microsoft you know what i'm saying like
xbox what i'm saying
is backed by microsoft so you know
taking them taking that risk with game
pass obviously is going to be a huge
advantage for them in comparison to sony
um but at the end of the day i think
both companies
are definitely going to make certain
moves and market certain things to try
to get people
on board i just think i just think that
microsoft
is is really running with the consumer
friendly
route and is trying to be as honest as
possible in the direction that they're
going in
and it's been working i'll be honest
with you it looks like it's been working
a lot of people
buying xboxes i think like a couple of
weeks ago they had microsoft
selling more xboxes in the us than
playstation which was very surprising
for me um but but uh
yeah like the xbox s has been selling
extremely well even if you don't buy
the game or buy the console you got
people signing up for game pass on pc
it's a win-win for microsoft they've
been uh doing a hell of a job
i still uh just i'm not i'm still
not sold on the s like that's one thing
that i think sony did better
than microsoft like could you imagine if
there was a series on all digital series
x
for 3.99 because it's just like if the
whole thing hinges
on that lower price what happens if sony
can lower the price on the digital
playstation before
uh microsoft can lower the price on the
series s
right it just seems like the 399 all
digital would have been
what would have been better and and the
reason i say that is
i'm just thinking about the lizard brain
of the consumer
the series s is literally marketed as
less than
right so when you bought when you buy a
series s
it's like because you either for some
people
it's a secondary council or they or they
or they um they they can't afford
to get the the the the is that is that
the mindset you want to go in
don't you want to feel like when you buy
one of these things you have the best
right you're going into it looking at it
as less than the heart i don't know
no that's that's not it you got to look
at it from the perspective of hardcore
and casual
there's a ton of people out there who
don't want to spend
500 on a console right
but if you can placate to them and say
hey you can play next generation games
for 299 and present this console as
if it really is this great console which
the s is even though it does
you got to remember that the s has the
same cpu
as the x they just don't have the same
gpu right they just don't have the same
gpu
so so for the most part you're going to
wind up getting
i guess you could say all of the all of
the uh
the the the processing of the x you just
won't graphically get what you get with
the x no no i'm completely understand
right like i i bought one and i i got it
like
i i got it for my girls because they
only played minecraft right
right right they got it upstairs and
they were just happy that everything
loaded faster
right i'm just saying like it works on
paper like it's a good idea on paper
but i'm just saying like actual human
people
will it turn out to be a good idea in
the long run i
i don't know i believe it has it's been
selling i
i heard that has been selling extremely
well and a lot of playstation guys
picked up the ass
a lot of players i think the whole point
of the s
was they're like look like clearly the
xbox one generation let's be real kind
of damage the brand
and they're like look like maybe people
aren't going to be comfortable
spending 500 500 on our brand anymore
but it's like and then they're looking
at it from you know everyone looking
from a casual consumer base they're like
we got a lot of people that just play
madden they're just playing 2k
they're just playing call of duty like
all those games will always run on they
on
on the s because they're they're they're
on pc so they're like
let's get that out there and we can have
a minecraft machine a fortnight machine
a 2k machine a madden machine
and they're like we know the hardcore
are always going to buy the best one
anyway so
they're winning on both and then not to
mention i'm seeing a lot of pc people
pick up the s
because they want that 60 frames which a
lot of
the s games have 60 frame modes and they
want that ssd on it
and i see people doing that because it
what the s does is it provides you
with an entry model that's at a good
affordable rate that you don't have to
100 commit to the microsoft brand and
then you have access to game pass on top
of that oh yeah in game pass
you can leave game stop buy it on amazon
and for 315
that first month you you're good but let
me go and get this
optimus code again with the smoke man
let me let me tell you octopus code
though one of the few people i know
that he's a huge troll and he got the
money to troll
any fan of fortune he ever wants to like
the fact that he's already
dropped 35 just to talk smack more we're
talking about uplifting the xbox brandon
optimus code with the 10 super chat i
didn't know this was a comedy show
optimus look man we're gonna have to
talk about this debate i don't know if
we're gonna i'm gonna do it yet
but i'm gonna have to get you man i'm
gonna have to get you
and i don't think i don't think you go
look you're very good at talking your
way out of
out of circles man but i got a truck
you're not circling my truck because i'm
gonna run right past you
we're out to talk about that man but you
know let let's let's bro
i'm i'm happy to get tagged into that
debate i'm just saying oh oh
everborn wants that wants to smoke too i
don't know man
but we can bring
ever born an attic versus j dub
and co that seems like a really bad
saturday cartoon that definitely gonna
need a ref for that
yeah well kyle gonna be the rap man kyle
gonna be the red
crazy so you know let's since we're
talking about the s
let's go over a little bit but my next
one xbox seems to be there they they're
they're taking the series series the
series consoles very very seriously
and they're making moves we see people
like windows central their shout out to
jazz corn really good
uh close friend of the realm and you
know we've been talking him and he's
like
there's a lot of speculation going on
everywhere you know jazz is always
saying
acquisition days and you know a lot of
people like to make fun of the
acquisitions because it's one of those
things where it's like
it's not games but i agree but i don't
agree
um we get we see something like obsidian
they make they've always made fantastic
games ninja theory make good games too
so
to me it's not necessarily they're
taking one scenario they're taking
everything seriously they're trying to
get the mobile market with x cloud
they're trying to get
all these studios to really fill out
game pass they're doing all this for
game pass
and we see all these acquisition rumors
we see all these game things that
they're making deals with uh io with
project dragon i don't know what the
hell that is but we're calling it
project dragon it's supposed to be
some kind of fantasy thing scenes like
mine cows type of game and i think
everborn likes those type of games but i
don't know ever born
uh extremely well like that so what i
want to ask you guys is
right now with the trajectory what do
you think microsoft's next
move is and it could be a realistic
thing you know it could be something
that you
think they're going but not necessarily
might not be true i just want to know
your guys's
important thing because i personally
feel like right now i'll say my
i think the moves that they're making is
in order to make their platform is
uh you know multi-genre as possible they
want to be diverse as possible they want
as many
genres that appeal to as many people as
possible going into game pass so they
can keep people there
and they want that constant slashing out
games to constantly keep people there
but before we go on with everborn
because i started with cal
over and over again i want to talk about
carlos in the two dollar super chat
uh let me try man wait goofy's captain
for sony 242 days still no
ssd no man this dude listens to king i
can already guarantee you that now
right now with this no ssd i can't
imagine look look look they they
definitely lacking that ssd and i feel
like
uh the playstation came out a little bit
more under underwhelmed in terms of
how the system and the features are than
the xbox because to me it feels like the
xbox
they always wanted this system to come
out doing exactly what they wanted to do
and i think you could see that with the
features the cross play
oh that's not really exclusive then but
you know the uh
the smart delivery which people assumed
was a gimmick which we've seen now it's
definitely not a gimmick
uh you know they have multiple different
performance modes and i think you know
they're definitely going to catch up to
the ssd but microsoft's definitely
killing them
but everborn what is the next moves that
you envision microsoft doing
what do i want them to do or what do i
think what do you think i want it can
can go in completely different roads
what do you think microsoft is doing
right now
and then probably the next year year and
a half so i don't
i don't personally like i don't know if
we're gonna get any
acquisitions any more acquisitions from
microsoft
uh this year i think they are still
trying to
integrate uh bethesda and
and they're trying to focus on their
their their road map now if something
comes up
sure but if if um
if and this is a big if
if netherrealm and tt games are
available
i think that they they really should try
to get them
because if not i think sony would pick
up netherrealm
and i think that um
um if sony does pick up netherrealm
then they basically own the fighting
game market right
and that that is something microsoft is
basically leaving off the table because
if they
if microsoft wants to get every genre in
game pass
what is their offering for people for
fans of fighting games
yeah and i think the the worst part is
they got something already but they
they're not making it and i think
that they don't have anyone to make it
and that that's that's part of the
bigger problem but i think if they
you get tt games and you basically
whether you get the lego license or not
you have someone to make banjo and and
um maybe a new cameo game right
um and and you have someone that can
make those all ages games for you and
then if you get
if you get um netherrealm you have
one of if not the most recognized
fighting ip well i think street fighter
is more recognizable
but that's neither here nor there uh you
have
you have someone to do that and you can
grow that studio
so you can grow netherrealm and say okay
this part of the studio is going to
continue to work on mk
this one's going to work on ki and ed
boon says he wants to work on an rpg
and you know matt booty doesn't say no
to anybody i think matt booty might have
the easiest job
like in all of microsoft he just calls
him up he's like what are you working on
and they
then they say games and he's like all
right call you next year
and then i don't think it's that simple
but i think if you want my opinion matt
booty got one of the worst jaws because
he
i imagine his thought process now
because before they bought uh bethesda
this man is responsible
for all of these studios and the output
that they do
sure when something happens who's going
to end up getting the
uh the look it's going to be phil
spencer because he's kind of the face of
xbox in a way
but who is phil spencer probably going
to be looking at matt booty
and then matt booty's gonna be looking
at all the heads of the studios that he
goes and visits
i think i don't think his job's quite
that simple but
i do get what you're saying i agree
i i think ever is on on the right path
and that
if you could pick up another realm
to me would be perfect because then you
would have you obviously
want those guys of all people to pick up
killer instinct
because of their combo system and how
great they do with mortal kombat they
would do an excellent job with killer
instinct as they both very mature bloody
gory type
titles so it kind of works in their
favor then obviously everybody wants
mortal kombat versus killer instinct so
that would be dope as well
and wants that too yeah and then you got
tt games
and that reminds me of uh when
microsoft was trying to make that halo
mega blocks game and uh you could do
that
you could finally pull off the halo mega
blocks game that you want to do being a
day
familiar with lego and all that stuff
like that um as well as maybe some other
uh kid games that you can have a run up
that alley as well because again
i've spoken with a long time ago spoken
with
uh gamer boss um who's the head of rare
um and asks them why don't they work on
something like a banjo and stuff like
that or bring those type of games back
and again
um i don't know how they feel now but at
the time when they were working on
when they were working on uh sea of
thieves the
the the the notion was that they just
didn't have the passion
for that game you got to have passion
for the development of certain games and
if you don't have that yeah
good right so i've always felt like
i don't care what they got to do they
got to bring banjo back in something
they got to do
yeah like even if even if rare i'm sure
there's some people
rare that wants to do a banjo maybe not
the whole damn studio
but i'm sure there's someone over there
that wants that feeling he's been there
long enough and he's like i'm
ready for uh my own project like yes i
did
i got an idea oh yeah you know how they
have no
idea what uh everwild is gonna be and
they're gonna revamp it
what if they revamp it into a banjo game
i think that's i think that's a stretch
stretch
i don't like if they somehow went from
everwhile to banjo-kazooie
i would be concerned for banjo at that
point like
um also so as far as like microsoft and
what i would want from them personally
um in their future i'll be honest with
you i
really want microsoft to purchase some
ips
there's certain ips i feel like that
worked in microsoft favor that were
really microsoft games but they belong
to other companies
so like i would want them to like say
for example bioware's not doing anything
with jade empire i would love him to
pick up that ip
um ninja gaiden i would love him to pick
up that ip if there was somehow some way
they could
purchase the ip from says studio ryze
it's another game
rise is a game that could have been
microsoft's final fantasy
and i've said this a thousand times i
thought rise
could be different places in the world
because you have
rise is just a game based on history
and you could easily do that with so
many different people throughout history
you could do that with alexander the
great
you could do that with genghis khan you
could do that with uh
with hannibal you can do that with
what's funny what's funny is is let me
say this real quick
you could go a different way with that
instead of it being someone big
you could do a game where you're
fighting their enemy and you lose like
well my thing is you don't have to be
you don't have to be the person
because uh what's the name like neo
nero was the villain right and he's a
he's a prominent figure in roman history
but my thing is is that this whole thing
play case on the gods and them playing
with man
right so you're going through our
history and the gods are constantly
playing with different
warriors a man but you're just you're
just a soldier you're just a regular
soldier within history you know i'm
saying and you're playing within this
story of whoever this great conqueror is
and that's how that story goes on i just
thought it would be dope if they were
able to pull that off somehow
see i thought for me i thought that they
were going to lean into it being more of
a god of war type thing because they
were
if you look at the ending to that game
it was kind of like
he was going on into a like a a another
realm sort of thing so i thought
i thought i was just sure that they were
gonna make a part two to that game that
never came out
um so i thought that they were gonna
follow along with that character who i
can't remember his name now
yeah i can't remember his name either
but no what they were saying was they
were basically
the gods were you know battling each
other who would win between nero and
this
this roman soldier and in the end he
dies obviously they take his soul to
wherever heaven it is that's what i mean
i thought they would it would
from there it would have went on into
to um uh mount olympus and it would have
it would have turned into some god of
war type thing yeah no i remember
i remember them saying that they were
the secret they were thinking about was
like more of them moving on to another
character and going to like britannia
and maybe introducing dragons and stuff
like that like imagine magical creatures
imagine if they didn't do something like
that and they did something like cal
wants to
wanted them to do and like like
alexander they're great you're like one
of his royal guard you know what i'm
saying like right
right that would have been fire like
that's what i'm saying but so you're
saying like
assassin's creed but good
assassin's creed but but just no we got
to say it but good but
good oh my god
yeah one of those type of things but
yeah i mean but i just of course i
always want them
being that disney has a star wars
license as a nice little republic fanboy
or just a star wars fan boy in general i
always wanted to do something with star
wars i heard that they got something in
the works
supposedly that's the rumor but we don't
know we don't know if you yeah you know
what the problem with that is though
like i think
um if you just buy an ip then you need
someone to make it
i feel like i do agree with you on that
but i feel like the amount of
different variety developers they have
right
the majority of ips they can buy they
can do that they can easily do knights
of the old republic they've already done
knights of the old republic so they can
always
make a newer version of nice little
republic for me personally
um you know but as far as the other ips
is concerned yeah obviously you would
need somebody to
you know build a studio to work out
those other ips it's just it's just
i i feel like you know the
the old microsoft to me gave up on
eyepiece too much
and that was the downfall of the
og xbox was that they relied in the in
in 360. they both relied too heavily on
third party
and we remember and those would fall
apart too easy
right like we remember 360 as this
amazing console with this amazing
library
but you know phil always said i and then
when i asked him about it because he
he called me out one time which was just
crazy and i was saying how 360 was such
an amazing platform
and how come you can't get back to that
and he just called me out he's like
what what games did we make that was
amazing
and i'm thinking like on my hand like
thinking in my head what was made in a
lot of the great games that we love for
360 was made by third-party companies
nothing
was made by first party other than the
major three like forza halo
fable you know gear and i think that's
stuff like that why one of his biggest
uh regrets is not picking up uh
bioware because he had that studio that
was a huge regret for him exactly
so you know with them now making the
moves that they did him picking up
obsidian
um picking up a lot of these rpgs
western rpg studios i i really think
this is the dream that he
initially wanted and now you can see a
lot of this stuff come to fruition
so i'm like hype man this this is this
is my platform of choice because i love
western rpg yes so let me
also just one other problem with like
buying ips like
i don't care what uh bioware
does with mass effect or even even
anthem
ea is never letting that go because
if all of their shareholders are going
to be like you let this ip go
and now look how they blew it up we
could have done that they always keep
hold on to these ips in the event that
they may bring it back later
so for for microsoft to buy an ip
it would have to be basically buying a
a independent studio that or or a bigger
publisher that owns that ip
whatever nobody's letting those go
absolutely that this is uh
obviously this is just a dream about i'm
just saying it would be nice if they
were able to pull something like that
off
yeah and definitely you know uh shout
out to the five dollars you got from
carlos
and vegito i definitely butchered that
we're gonna move past that uh
ps fans excited for remasters remakes
and directors
this is the new thing to make fun of
director cuts
uh no uh not new games shake my uh
head microsoft saved e3 sony couldn't
save july the 8th microsoft saved their
oh my god man that's funny microsoft
couldn't say
july the 8th microsoft saved their own
state of play
yo man we're going to move faster that
was that was a pretty funny little bit
like when it comes to me what i think
they should do is
they should focus uh on kind of like a
two-pronged approach
i think they should buy netherrealm if
that's a possibility and i think the
reason they should buy another room is
because out of all the stuff that they
could buy right now
that is what they need the most because
they need killer instinct back people
want killer instinct back and i think
there's enough fan base
to justify that purchase i think that
they need to be a little bit more active
in the japanese market
they need to do something there i don't
know if it's by studio
i think you know they're not going to
buy a studio and bring back maybe you
know try to work with miss walker to
bring back
you know lost odyssey you do maybe a
remake a loss odyssey first like bring
it back
yeah i got it i got you addict
buy netherrealm and tt games for the
reason we discussed before
then you buy sega and then give sonic to
tt games
well that'd be cool you know it would be
crazy but if they buy seg i don't think
they need to do stuff like that because
like if they have sega
they'll have access to persona they'll
have access to like yakuza like
like buying second would fix a lot of
the issues they got like
and let's just be re i just don't know
if it's a realm of possibility
i think out of all the rumors that's
going around that's the one that makes
the most sense
but i don't know if that's something
that's a realistic
thing i i honestly i don't think they're
gonna buy
any major uh japanese publisher maybe
they'll get a studio and even then i
don't know i think
i think the what they have is tango
and they're gonna have to rock out with
that for a little while
so it's like i said like you get
if they don't buy the japanese studios
what they do is
work with work work it with with game
pass talk to square enix
talk to you know talk to sega look they
have they're having a good relationship
with both those companies right now
hit up sega be like what is it going to
take for persona 6 to be in game past
day and day
what is it going to take for dragon
quest 12 to be in game pass day and date
i feel like that's cheaper than buying a
studio and funding an entire ip i would
prefer the latter i would prefer them to
hone their own
game and to have their exclusive to
their own platform
but if that is not a realistic
expectation
then they can go that direction i think
people would
definitely gravitate towards game pass
if you can get dragon quest 12
day and date in there whenever that
comes out if you could get you know
persona
uh persona 6 day and date when that game
comes out
if you can get the next yakuza like a
dragon dang date when that game comes
out put in people's minds that
game passes the service for you if
you're into jrpgs
and and sort of just japanese games in
general
i think that would be a huge win for
them right like
if they don't you're right they don't
need to buy those studios if they get
them in the service and the people who
are into those games
that's a whole market of people that
would just say listen i know i get all
the japanese stuff
in game pass that's that's where i'm
trying but i i ain't gonna act like
i i could use a missed walker game i
ain't gonna act like i couldn't like
you give me lost artists you guys
thought i fanboy over fable
oh my god you don't even know how much i
fan what about blue dragon
blue dragon i know i got i got okay
we're gonna break it down now you
brought it up
okay we ain't talking about blue dragon
i'm just we ain't gonna go too far
because i i got like another 10 minutes
and that's all
look blue dragon i feel like would be
the
safer bet because dragon quest 11 did so
well
and there's similar uh art choices and i
feel like people gravitate towards they
both made by akira toriyama yeah they
they would
gravitate towards a blue dragon but then
you have on the other spectrum you got
lost odyssey
that's more of a realistic approach and
it's got a great story but
i i don't know which one would do the
best i just don't
uh what would you know i just want
microsoft to be more diverse in the
japanese market i think cal can agree
with me
you know i feel like every time we get
an inch like
sony comes in spends their money and we
get punched back a mile
we finally get the dragon quest
franchise and we've had final fantasy
for the past like 10 years it feels like
and now we've lost final fantasy it
feels like so it makes
sense it happens so final fantasy
doesn't have the same impact
it doesn't not even remotely like not
like back in the day
you know what i'm saying like witcher is
bigger at this point than final fantasy
i'm looking forward to that
um director's cut i'm at the end of that
game but i'm just holding off until all
the new updates come out
um but i just think that uh i mean i i
think you're right as far as like
microsoft
uh maybe they might not buy a japanese
studio i've always said they needed to
make their own studio
open up a studio in japan and hire new
talent or poach
people from other studios like you did
before um
when it comes to like you did with like
sony and
rockstar and stuff like that and not to
mention like the
i think it would be like not necessarily
mad cheap for them but the
the american to you know i think it's
the yen over there in it or the europe
yeah it's lower
than the americans yeah so so i think it
would cost them like
not necessarily dirt sheep but they can
compete over there relatively
easily yeah yeah i don't know we'll see
what happens i i they definitely need to
uh compete in that market more
japanese games have very uh
depending on what you're playing a very
niche
especially to the american populace um
but the one thing i give playstation is
because they have such those niche games
you wind up grabbing a large diverse
people and that's what microsoft needs
to do you know
the thing isn't that the thing isn't
that sony
is amazing at diversity it's just a
simple fact that there's a lot of titles
that they have that small groups of
people play and if you know
that there's a a small group of people
that play a particular game and is only
on this platform
that small group turns into a large
group over time because people
know the only place to get that game is
on this platform so
you know microsoft has to be able to get
some of those niche titles as well
and put that on their platform so they
continue to play it like one of the
games one of the platforms microsoft is
really good at
is those shumps those shoot-em-ups those
little space shooters
those little 2d shooters they love those
games we get those games
all the time and a lot of people
gravitate to xbox to play those games
i agree man i agree i think we can all
agree here man we've been
uh you know xbox fans for a long time
and
the brand's done so much better in the
past 10 years they got they
like especially cal me and cal been at
this for a minute
like we was there when when when we had
to like
we had to like close the door it's like
one of those things i'm an xbox fan then
you have to shut the door lock it
headboard it like chain it like
you don't want a lot of people knowing
that man i've been an xbox fan since the
rocks snatched them
uh yeah and you know i definitely
appreciate you guys from coming on here
you know everborn man tell them
tell tell the realm what they can catch
you at man where can they catch you
oh man you can catch me at everborn saga
everywhere and that comment earlier
about the eagle landing that is because
all 1500 of the books that we ordered
from their kickstarter
have just come in today and i will be i
will be packaging those up and sending
them out
to all uh all the backers of the the the
ariel's adventure campaign
and very special announcement i don't
think may maybe i said this
last night not sure but uh everborn will
be
at new york comic con this year that's
the first time for us so it's a very
very
patient brother we thank you sir we got
a booth there
um and once i ship everybody's books
which will take me a couple of days
we are going to release ariel's
adventure chapter one on the everborn
saga website
um and you know we do this show every
thursday king joins us a couple weeks
ago maybe
maybe we can get him to come this
thursday to talk about uh black widow
and the season finale of loki that's
every thursday and on my channel which
is everborn soccer on youtube
we just talk movie movies and tv news
things like that
and then saturday we do the gaming
circle podcast with uh k asante also
he's also on the thursday show and we do
that on his channel so everborn saga
everywhere
and check us out on the real and
everborn soccer.com and all that stuff
thank you so much attic uh it was good
anytime you need me on for addicts uh
world show
you just you just uh hit me up in the
dms yeah yeah and i appreciate uh you
know you've always been a very
entertaining person in the podcast
you're definitely one of those people
that uh that if i see on the panel like
let me let me talk pop in and see what's
what's being said
uh cal let me tell you about this man
cal
like yo he is one of the very few people
i know that can do solo shows i do solo
shows but it don't sound nothing like
i can't i don't like not being able to
hear like a reaction from someone else
cal dead ass can talk to himself man
and that's not like a clown on cow that
is a very
unique skill that there's only one other
individual in this community that i've
seen could do it just as well same
and that's ghost uh uh man i keep
forgetting his actual name that he says
uh a sigma ghost what's what's his full
name saga
saga everborn oh uh ghosts
accepted ghosts they're the only two
people i know that are so fluent with
solo shows man
it'd be making me jealous that i can't
do it like it does man
but but where can people find you man uh
i'm making a comeback um
just a lot of people don't know tick
podcast has retired
and i am going solo so i will have a new
podcast dropping in
august called super paw shots um
you can catch me on twitter at super paw
shots
um right now if you want to follow me
and uh yeah man i'll be making a little
comeback doing my own thing now as
uh you know the the superhero of xbox
kal-el
and um you know super power shots be
making this run and i'll be talking
about xbox and gaming and stuff
like that as well and uh you know just
continue to keep
doing my thing yeah definitely go over
there when he starts that it's like i
said man super paul charlotte says that
you know i don't know if he'll ever have
guests but generally it's always so low
but may
like he'd be making a c like that solo
stuff
i'm telling you guys like i know a lot
of people in the chat because a lot of
people in the chat probably have never
done a podcasting thing
but it's really hard to do the [ __ ] by
yourself like
it is because you start like your mind
starts going i guess maybe if like
do you have like a like sub to like
write your thoughts down or is a lot of
that
see that is insane to me
it depends man like you know it depends
like
if i have a lot on my mind to say and
i'm trying to make a point
like what i try to do is i try to i try
to bring up the topic and i try to make
a point and then i try to
uh i try to
give facts to that point so it makes
sense so things are logical
so people understand where i'm coming
from so like a lot of times all that
stuff just flows out of me man it just
it just comes out it's just like i don't
know how it happens but it just happens
it's just crazy and definitely
when he starts that man you guys need to
go over there support that man you know
he
great content it's always been good
concert and you know one thing i want to
point out real quick in the chat before
we go
is that man hustling motivate always
been a very
very good person of the realm probably
one of the the key mods that we have
go over there and give this man some
love man like
he's over there streaming right now tell
him iop sent you and
actually you know tell him addict sent
you okay i tell him adam sent you
because
dude's always been a good influence like
out of everyone that deserves
any type of success on here man hustle
has always been extremely
extremely supportive to every community
i can think of
go there and show him some love and
until next week we will see you